okay at home prices uh prices are up in
the month of october but it falls in the
month of november so i'm going to read
you both of these stories first one
about is by cnbc
the sme corelogic case shiller 20 city
home and price index out tuesday climbed
18.4 in october from a year earlier the
gain marked a slight declaration from
19.1 year-over-year increase
in september but was about uh in line
with what the economists have been
expecting all 20 cities posted double
digit annual gains the hottest market
was phoenix up 32.3 wow tampa
28.1 miami 25.7 minneapolis and chicago
smallest increases
chicago and minneapolis smallest
increases anybody's surprise
11 and a half
percent last week mortgage rates fell
to uh 3.05 for the benchmark of 30 years
and fixed rates are 2.66 for 15 year
fixed rate home loans then yahoo story
comes out about november national home
prices fell in november as sales
remained risk although home prices
across the nation remain risk november
brought some relief for buyers as median
sale prices fell 2.9 to 330 the largest
monthly decline since the beginning of
pandemic since the beginning of the
pandemic it dropped three percent
meanwhile the number of available homes
remains low the number of homes for sale
fell to a new loan 14-year history of
report declining 17.7 percent one
product at a smaller home inventory is
that houses aren't staying on the market
for too long the average home sold or
november was on the market for 29 days
that was only the sixth time in history
of the report that the average time on
the market dipped below 30 days tom i'm
going to come to you with this here
first if i'm thinking about if i'm
thinking about buying or selling how
should i think if i'm a buyer how should
i think if i'm a seller what are your
thoughts well hear me know and hear very
clearly you need to get into a house as
soon as you can
and
sensible negotiation of course because
we are heading to be renter nation
translate these three facts number
available homes remains low
stuff that's on the market is on the
market less than 30 days what that means
is anything that comes out there is
selling getting bought up investors are
buying this up corporate investors are
buying it up pe investors are buying it
up because there is a ton of capital out
there uh pat you seem to have mentioned
on a few podcasts that we've printed a
lot of money in the last year yep that
capital is being
lands
you know upstream not downstream with
people it lands upstream at the end of
the day and we're about to become
renter nation because what you see here
is big money is buying up these homes
and
you're going to be renting so if you i
don't know what that means tom so i'm
confused here so you said go buy because
big money's buying up properties and
you're going to be a renter unpack that
for me yeah so if you can't get into a
house soon within your means within your
means
you are probably going to be in a
position where you're renting because
these houses are being bought up there's
a lot of corporate buyers out there
there's a lot of pe
so corporate buyers are buying regular
residential homes yeah not even condos
not even townhouses just homes single
family matter of fact i read an article
this past week where there was a pe
investor said i think we're in the early
innings
actually
and it was it was a rod's partner a-rod
who said i think we're in the early
innings of the single-family home
investment market where you buy large
consolidations of homes run them through
property management and america becomes
renters of single-family homes not
talking condos not talking apartments
that's where this is going you're saying
this only applies to single-family homes
no dissipation no no what i'm saying is
saying there's always been large
investors that bought large numbers of
mdus multi multi-dwelling units mfus
multi-family units now it's coming to
they're buying out neighborhoods of
single-family homes so i
tell you i've seen this firsthand and i
can't tell you how right he is and this
is the conversation that we've had the
rent is too damn high guy up in new york
this is what happened
corporate corporations came in in new
york you're saying yeah in the city yeah
but zudo number one of them all right
they come in and they buy entire blocks
and then what they do is they insulate
themselves from any sort of market
prices so a year ago when everybody said
new york's dead it's leaving everybody's
leaving prices never went down on rent
because these guys can take as many
losses as they can they're selling off
shares they're getting it on both sides
they're selling off shares on what they
own based on the price points
exactly so they sell the shares off and
they're making money then they take
losses off of the off of uh off of what
they earn if the assets underperform so
they insulate themselves from any sort
of market function you look at yourself
and you say how in the hell is this
still twenty three hundred dollars for a
one bedroom up in jersey city well
because everything's twenty three
hundred 300 they set the market price
and now they're going even as far as
zillow they have this uh they got sued
for a lot of money i think it's still in
court they were are they they were
artificially raising the prices
based on the corporate entities that own
the prices so you own a house right you
can't sit on the house for two years
you're a normal human being you're like
all right i got to get a good offer and
i got to go live somewhere but if you're
a corporation you can sit on that house
for 10 years you hold the asset you use
it as as a leverage to get other assets
yeah and you and and you just
artificially inflate the price in the
market so what really happens here man
we want to talk about like income
inequality this is where's aoc when it
comes to this [ __ ] where's the democrats
when it comes to this who has access to
credit
credit score is the number one income
inequality in the world it's not
education it's not money it's not salary
it's access to finance who has access to
the money that you need to get this
mortgage correct and the leverage that
you talked about
these these investors they're not paying
3.05 percent they're paying less
so the interest cost that they have to
recoup there when they're renting it to
people is low it's all the time they're
taking the money from themselves correct
they're loaning the money out to
themselves here's a question for you
next year's midterms okay during
midterms
do rates go up the rates go down do you
flatline the rates
do you manage because the formula with
inflation is what if inflation is high
how do you control it you raise your
increased rates
okay right so inflation at 6.8 do you
think we're gonna crack seven percent
when the next report comes up okay so
let's just say we crack seven percent a
lot of us think we're already there all
right some people are saying we're at
ten or eleven percent but let's just say
the numbers come out publicly we crack
seven if we crack seven how quickly you
think the call is made to powell to
raise rates to control inflation well
didn't powell already announced that
he's going to raise seven times is what
goldman sachs is saying it's going to be
raised next i think the call is made 30
seconds before they make the
announcement on the inflation okay so
fine if that happens all i want to know
i'm the buyer i'm the seller
rates going up rates going down 2022.
am i a buyer am i a seller what what am
i in 2022 knowing the fact that to
control inflation i got increased the
rates
i
you got to be a buyer right now you got
to be a buyer if you can be if you've
got the savings and you can get in you
need to be a buyer because i don't think
the these asset
we may have a bubble where it pops down
like 0-809 but we're back above that and
then some and then some right so i think
you got to be a buyer within your ways
and means yeah but you got to be
if
otherwise because there's an appreciable
asset under that that the government is
going to i mean look at fannie mae here
three percent 2.66
that's very low cost i agree that you
need to be a buyer but where i disagree
is that you have to be within your means
i think that right now if they're giving
out free money like candy and everybody
is using that free money you get yours
too right now if they give if anybody i
know and this goes against everything
that i was brought up believing this
goes against everything that i was
raised this goes against all the
austrian economics that i believe in but
if you have access to credit right now
take it take every single dollar
somebody will give you the free money
train the gravy chain has to come to an
end at some point and even though i
agree with you as long as you can
service it you have to be even at a low
interest rate you have to be able to
every single dollar they want to give
you you take because i guarantee you
they are taking it i guaran out of that
stimulus we just did what three trillion
dollars three trillion what did you get
what did you get america twelve hundred
bucks
you're gonna pay for every single
diamond at twelve twelve hundred bucks
you're gonna you're gonna pay for every
single diamond of that stimulus what did
you get twelve hundred dollars you gotta
get yours at this point man well listen
guys they're getting there i think you
guys are both missing the boat here you
guys are making blanket statements i
think it's where you're at in life if
you're gonna be in the same city for the
next decade and you've got kids and you
want to lock down you know you're going
to be and you'll be stability sure buy
but if you're like most of america right
now and you're working from anywhere and
you're working remote you're moving your
groove and your next thing you know
you're live in new jersey now you're in
dallas now you're back in new york now
you're back in in south florida you
don't know where you're going to be the
last thing you freaking need is to lock
yourself within the mortgage because
there's something called house rich cash
poor because it's actually it's this is
a fact out there that 100 of
foreclosures happen when you have a
mortgage
so there's a lot of people out there
that
buy a house because they're fed buy a
house american dream you got to buy a
house and they get in the house they're
like holy [ __ ] i didn't realize that i
need furniture for this house and i
didn't realize that i got to pay
maintenance and i got to pay taxes i get
insurance and i can't afford this
[ __ ] house yeah but pat wrote an
amazing article what what you did to
write that article
back in 2008 where you're making people
were enabled above their means yeah
exactly and that's what happens in 2008
and tell us about that article you wrote
denver post 2012 years ago it was a uh
i think it ended up being a cover story
there you go home buying go go with cold
clear logic and i was renting at the
time yeah and i had a half a million
dollars in a bank and i was still
renting at the time wait wait wait wait
wait wait
scroll back up we're not going to go
right past those bell bottoms yeah
that's a bell button i'm a bell-bottom
guy what's going on here yeah
bell-bottom guy yeah yeah so
full disclosure i'm in a very similar
situation were you married at that point
yet or no uh yeah uh yes okay we have
t-call already okay gotcha i'm in a
similar situation where i've got a lot
of cash in the bank and i'm renting and
where have i lived in the last
24 months but but adam you're you're a
you're an anomaly okay because you
choose to live this minimalist life at
the age of 40. that's not a very very
common so you're not everybody you're
probably one in a thousand of a person
at your age that's choosing to live like
you you're living below your means
you're a saver you're very you're not a
gucci guy you're not a ferragamo guy
you're not you're not any of those guys
you don't i don't see with a rolex
you're very much of a yeah you're
exactly that the the rich man like
what's the
next story
the millionaire next door
that's who you are
i read that book it changed my life
exactly who you are so your philosophy
works for a hundred percent of people if
they applied it's gonna work for them
my question is more or less of somebody
right now that's sitting there saying
who has the means
who is got money in the bank they got
two three hundred thousand dollars but
they got a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand to put on the down payment and
they can still afford to go out there
and live in that place
should they still wait a year or should
they go pull
you know make the decision to buy a
house in 2022 that's what i'm asking i
think what he's saying
the way i see it from his perspective is
the following
the people that bought all of these
properties it's like a comp here's what
i mean by comp uh say for example
uh
hypothetically uh a
i don't know let's pick an example of an
insurance company
say aig
is about to buy
40 of his company
for 200 million dollars okay
and his company that is buying for 200
million dollars aig is putting their own
money to buy that 20 uh 40 percent you
get to going out two million okay out of
the 200 million dollars which is what
one percent of 200 million right
aig is optimistic they can turn this
thing to five billion dollar company
within the next three years do you think
aig is going to let you lose your money
so you're you're banking on there's no
way they're going to lose 198 million
dollars my 2 million is going to make
money so these private equity guys are
not going to let themselves lose money
so you have to bank on the fact that
they're not doing this
assuming they're going to lose money
they kind of know what they're doing
long term so you had you that's a good
point you're almost going with them
that's what he's trying to say so and i
think the rent's going to flip right i
think because remember rent rent has to
contain
has to contain marginal value interest
maintenance and the property taxes it
will and so i think the rents are going
to be above ownership costs
are you familiar with something called
the the price to rent ratio yeah exactly
right but you that when you have the
discount when the money is so cheap the
offset there for the tax deduction on
the interest totally totally totally
understand so so buying a house today is
cheaper than renting the same exact
course no it depends on what city you're
in well
up to something called price to rent
ratio but adam i think that this is this
is the part that that you're right i
think is escaping you is the landlord
shifting well that's the thing once they
own all the property
once you have no option of ownership
they can make the rent whatever they
want
what what are you gonna do they can turn
around tomorrow and they can be like all
right rent's four grand for this one
bedroom it's a form of a monopoly yeah
what what can you do they own there it's
market control
so unless you roll down tyler
which by the way if you own one of those
properties you can do as well keep going
you know one of the one of the best
quotes in the in the sopranos guys the
best quote in the sopranos was you know
i don't want any california [ __ ] and
the second best quote is keep going i'll
tell you what buy land aj because god
ain't making any more of it all right
yeah by the way by the way you don't
need to even look at it i'll just tell
you what case studies with families that
we're looking at okay
i got a lot of guys right now that are
looking at buying homes and it ranges
from half a million dollar homes it
ranges all the way up to 10 million
dollar homes the guys are trying to buy
right around me
every single one of them they come back
and they call me rent is 50 percent
higher than me buying the place
rent
of the same house is 50 higher than
buying the place it's moving guess what
the biggest challenge is with most
people having a down payment right so if
you're buying a community if you if
you're buying a million dollar home do
you have that 20 to put down 200 000 so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]